[Music]
get your nad levels up you can do that
with being a little bit hungry you can
also do that by restricting the total
amount of protein that you bring on
board so eating a lot of steak would be
the worst thing you could do never
exposing your body to any changes in
temperature it's probably another thing
basically everything that makes your
body happy and sedentary and unstressed
is bad for you and the reason is that
you're not engaging your survival
circuits but now we can kick those
survival chains into action by putting
our bodies under a bit of stress or
mises or eating plants with those
molecules that signal stress we call
that Zeno hormesis and that is right now
with the exception of some clinical
trial proof that exercise and dieting is
really the best thing we can do for our
bodies exercise is a treatment for the
body that actually puts the entire
system in a state of defense and so it's
less about getting the blood to flow and
more about getting your tissues to act
younger and that's really the huge
benefit that you get from exercise
that's David Sinclair and this is the
retro podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast here's a couple
uncontroversial facts everybody grows
old and everybody dies but is this
actually set in stone does it have to be
this way
what if we thought about aging as a
disease as a curable disease and what
would you do and what would the world
look like if we could suddenly live to
be 200 plus years my name is rich roll I
am your host this is my podcast and this
is but a few of the topics we explore
today with one of the world's leading
scientific authorities on longevity
aging and how to slow its effects David
Sinclair is a professor in the
department of genetics at Harvard
Medical School he's co-director of the
Paul F Glenn Center for the biological
mechanisms of aging he obtained his PhD
in molecular genetics at the University
of New South Wales Sydney in 1995 and
worked as a postdoctoral researcher at
MIT where among other things he Co
discovered the cause of Aging for yeast
David is the co-founder of several
biotech companies he's also the
co-founder and coach Eve editor of the
journal aging his work has been featured
in a variety of books documentaries and
media including 60 minutes Nightline and
Nova he's also an inventor with 35
patents to his name has been lauded as
one of the top 100 Australian innovators
and he made Time magazine's list of the
100 most influential people in the world
finally he is the author of a new
upcoming book entitled lifespan the
revolutionary science of why we age and
why we don't have to which comes out
September 10 and is currently available
for pre-order check the link in the show
notes to check that out if you enjoyed
my episode with dr. Valter Longo a
fellow brilliant warrior in the
longevity space we mentioned him a few
times today that was episode 367 or if
you happen to hear David Joe Rogan's
podcast a few months ago which was great
by the way
then I'm fairly confident that you're
gonna love this one so this is a
mind-blowing conversation on everything
ageing longevity the scientific
mechanisms that contribute to biological
degeneration and the hard work that
David and others are devoting to both
better understanding these mechanisms as
well as learning how to prevent and even
reverse them I want to say upfront it's
not just about living as many years as
possible but more about how to live as
vibrantly and as energetically as
possible for as long as possible that's
really the goal here I should also say
that this one gets pretty deep in the
weeds scientifically which is of course
perfect for the geeks among us but it's
also grounded in practical takeaways for
everybody in addition to being a lovely
guy David is a true pioneer it is an
honor and it is a privilege to share
this brilliant man's work and wisdom
with you today so without further ado I
give you dr. David Sinclair good to have
you here thank you for doing this things
are having me on I'm excited to talk to
you this is a subject of personal
interest of course and I think interest
of everybody and the work that you're
doing is really not only fascinating but
obviously revolutionary or potentially
revolutionary so first off thank you for
the work that you're doing and I look
forward to exploring this with you I
think a good place to start would be
just sharing a little bit about what got
you interested in this field to begin
with like why longevity why ageing
anti-aging yeah sure
I think we're at were all the same when
we're about the age of four or five we
realized that we're not going to be
around forever and and even scarier for
a young kid your parents are gonna die
and your grandparents gonna die and your
pet and cats gonna die so I remember
going through that very vividly my
grandmother
who essentially raised me was a very
honest person and she would just tell it
as it is and she said to me as a four
year old yeah yeah I'm not gonna be
around your parents gonna die your cat's
gonna die and you're gonna die in on
that's a bit of a shock to a four year
old who you know you've probably still
believed in close at four it was brutal
and that may be the turning point in my
life but what most kids do and it's been
well studied is that they bury that
thought it's just too sad to the men
it's distracting to dwell on that every
day of your life so we actually
typically forget about it by the age of
six or seven and then it doesn't emerge
till we get into our late 40s early 50s
and we think okay maybe there is no such
thing as immortality but now up until
then most people don't even think about
it I feel like we still don't really
think about it we certainly don't talk
about it and death is almost a verboten
subject and our exposure to the reality
of death and aging in its most you know
late in mature forms is something we do
our best to whitewash and remove from
our field of vision yeah I agree with
that and it really takes a lot of
courage to be able to think deeply and
ponder your loved ones mortality and
your own and so I also I don't think
about it too much myself though I
probably do think about it more than
most but seriously I think if all of us
right now would consider what they have
right now and losing all of that and
most likely not seeing most of these
people ever again if any of them I mean
that's a pretty sad thing and I don't
mean to depress everybody but that's
something really worth appreciating that
we are here right now most of us are
healthy but that will not last mm-hmm
yeah I feel like we we all
intellectually understand that to be the
case but I think there's something
innately human about being in denial of
that truth in order to kind of get
through the day like on some level I
have this signal in the back of my mind
going yeah I know it's gonna happen but
yeah I might just evade that
somehow I think I'm gonna get around
that yeah well that's what we do that's
why we survive as human beings it's
pretty cruel thing to have a species
that's conscious of its own mortality
it's not a happy thing and most animals
actually as far as we know all animals
except us go through life not knowing
that they're gonna die mm-hmm and that
their their family's gonna die but we
are burdened with that but as a coping
mechanism and and I believe that it's
probably evolutionary wired into our
genome that we don't think about that
because people who did always worry
about dying that their tribes probably
died out thousands of years ago right
well it can be it can be paralyzing -
and you talk about this in that you were
nice enough to send me that introduction
to your new book that's coming out at
the end of the year and you you talk
about your grandmother and the impact
that she's had on you and her sort of
lifestyle antidote to this ethos of
living your life in accordance with a
ticking clock right that she wanted to
live this joyous I mean she sounded like
amazing right she's living this joyous
childlike existence you know until her
body could no longer keep up with her
spirit right well I as a young kid she
was still in her 40s she had my father
when she was 14 15 and so that that
allowed her to be very young as a
grandmother but she was also mentally
young she was vivacious it's she's one
of those people where you you know that
she's got so much energy she can't
contain it so she's she came from
Hungary she escaped Hungary after 1956
when Russia cracked down on a revolution
when his far away from Europe as she
could which was Australia Sydney is
where she settled and why where I grew
up uh and there she felt free
she was oppressed for most of her life
with rape and pillage going on and she
got to Australia and everyone had enough
to eat and they had money and they had
sunshine and she just loved life and so
she was one of the first people I hear
to wear a bikini in Australia and she
got taken off Bondi Beach for in the
1950s wearing one of those it's
incredible to hear that knowing what I
you know
knowing what Bondi Beach represents that
she was like the first person to wear a
bikini on that Beach and got chastised
yeah these days you get chastised for
wearing a top yeah if you're a woman but
yeah she went lived in New Guinea with
the natives for a while and hung out
there by herself my father had to go get
her because she was probably drinking a
fair amount
she says she tasted human flesh up there
with the cannibal so that's pretty big
thing for a woman to do that in the
1960s yeah so she was great she raised
me to just love life to always stay
young and she says grown-ups ruin
everything
stay young yeah she had this mantra this
a melon poem rain about maintaining your
your six year old self throughout your
life that's right now we are six and she
would read that to my brother and me and
she would just say make the most of your
life stay young don't listen to the
naysayers adults are mostly naysayers
and leave them leave a mark do what's
good for Humanity she said she was a
humanist at heart even towards the end
of her life a declared humanist and so
her goal and my goal is the same which
is nothing matters except making the
world a better place after you've been
here profound especially given that so
much of the work that you do is at the
cutting edge and it's impossible that
that's not going to ruffle feathers and
create you know a cadre of naysayers who
are trying to take it down a peg well
yeah I mean it hasn't been an easy
career even from the outset has volta
long ago and your shorten rightly said
it was rough in the old days studying
aging wasn't even considered a true
science but like most careers if you try
to push the envelope and say things that
others have never said before you will
have people who try to pull you down but
it's uh you know I'm pretty stubborn and
I keep my eye on the goal which is to
help humanity so these daily fights and
and things don't really get me down so
much right so your grandmother has this
profound impact on you and you're a
young enterprise
University student in New South Wales
and it from what I gather there was sort
of one particular lecture that kind of
turned things for you that got you out
here to the United States well there was
a prior to hearing the lecture I was I
remember sitting playing cards with my
friends and that I didn't try that hot
in college or or in school mostly with
playing cards and drinking heavily but I
do remember one moments telling them all
do you realize we're probably the last
generation to live quote unquote
and natural lifespan and others in
downstream of us our descendants are
going to live a lot healthier and longer
lives than us and we've been born one
generation too early do you realize how
sad that is and they just went yeah deal
the cards David shut up
but that stuck with me and so when I
heard the lecture from Lenny gurantee
who was an MIT professor still is he
came and he talked about a project that
had just started up in his lab over in
Boston to study yeast aging same yeast
that's in bread and beer and I was
studying yeast for my PhD so I knew
yeast intimately there were my friends I
would look at the mother microscope and
what he told me was they age and I
didn't know that most people don't know
that yeast cells get old they get fat
they get slow to get sterile did you
know that there are little creatures and
they're a lot smaller than and we are
but they have the same struggles through
life they have to find mates they
breathe and so I thought that was a
wonderful way to start studying aging
because if we can't figure it out for
yeast
we've got no hope figuring it out for
humans sure so that begins this lifelong
journey this exploration into into aging
and longevity so before we embark on on
that let's define our terms I mean what
is aging from your perspective well I've
come to the conclusion that aging is a
condition I will be bold and say it
should be declared a disease and that
often strikes people most people as
ludicrous but but let's
to do some thought experiments here one
being if if I was to tell you rich that
I just found your real birth certificate
okay you say well what is it now I'm
telling you unfortunately you're a
hundred years old are you gonna want to
die tomorrow you're healthy you're fit
so that the think the point there is
nobody who's healthy and vigorous and
enjoys their daily life and enjoys their
family wants to die so often I ask
people about how long do they want to
live and the typical answer is I I don't
want to live beyond 80 and God forbid
100 and that's because they don't think
of people who are old as being anything
worth idle yeah right so that that's one
aspect on the aging as a disease if you
go to the Merck Manual of geriatrics
which is the Bible of this field the
definition of of a disease versus aging
is very simple it's a 50% cut off if
something bad happens to your body and
you're in a minority in the population
that's a disease something worth
treating but if it happens to 51% then
hey that's natural that's just aging we
should just deal with it that's what God
gave us and that's ridiculous you know
if you're off by a fraction of a percent
its aging by that argument diabetes and
heart disease are just conditions of
life given how many people are
succumbing to these diseases
well heart disease is about 40% so
that's borderline right what was 51% who
might just say hey too bad that's aging
uh-huh yeah well dis-ease right it is a
you know a diseases is a condition in
which your body is out of balance in
which there is a lack of equilibrium and
processes are not you know functioning
properly so by that argument it makes
perfect sense that you would qualify it
as edge well if we can call it whatever
we want you know it's it's our world we
can create it ourselves and there so
there's no law that says aging is not a
disease just as there isn't a law that
says it is a disease but what do we
choose to call it really determines how
we go after it how we classify it and
classifications have a big impact on
regulation and right now there's no
country in the world that
considers aging a condition that can be
treated so even if a doctor had a pill
that could treat aging that doctor could
could but but it'd have to be off-label
prescribe a medicine to help you that's
crazy that's really crazy that probably
the best thing a doctor could do for you
is to give you a medicine that would
prevent pretty much all chronic old-age
diseases but right now that's not
possible because of the regulation but
we don't die of old age we die of
diseases that are precipitated by
declining well-being right I mean how
does that how do you think about that
all right well let's take cancer for
example that if you smoke it increases
your chance of getting lung cancer by
about fivefold and we all we worry about
that you try to we spend billions of
dollars on on trying to treat cancer and
prevent smoking getting to the age of 60
increases your chance of cancer by a
thousandfold aging is the root cause of
by far
orders magnitude of all of these
diseases that we eventually get they're
not separate things
aging is what caused these and how we
need people do you know that get heart
disease and Alzheimer's in their 20s
very few the reason is because the body
is young enough to fend its fend off
these diseases so my approach to this is
that if we can figure out why we get old
and how to reprogram the body the cells
in the body to be young again we won't
get those diseases and even if we have
the disease those diseases the body can
heal itself like we were 20 again mm-hmm
okay so then when we age what is
actually happening on a cellular level
all right so let's go back just fifty
years to set the stage of where we are
now because it's pretty exciting times
50 years ago let's go back to the 1950s
everyone was excited about radiation or
scared probably is better way to put it
and there are a lot of theories that
were put out so Leo's Leo Szilard
Peter Medawar came up with these
theories about the mutation hypothesis
that we lose our genetic information
mutations occur and they accumulate
during our lifetime
and that's what causes aging and
mutations largely occur by radiation
that were exposed to it's like a
breakdown in the structure of the DNA
right right so you lose the information
in the genome but what's Happ two things
have happened eat just in my lifetime
first of all that idea that mutations
themselves cause aging has been largely
disproved you can make mice that have
loads of mutations you can knock out
their ability to repair these things and
they don't get old they live a normal
healthy lifespan hmm that's just one
example of a whole little live litany of
examples of why that theory from the
1950s is in my view most likely to be
not as prominent if not just downright
wrong this big thing that happened early
in my career in the 1990s was the
discovery that there are control genes
that control our body's health and
longevity and so single genes control
health so it's not as complicated as we
once thought you can make one mutation
and an organism whether it's a yeast in
a case of my working voltar's Cynthia
Kenyans done worms these organisms live
a lot longer ostensibly by mimicking
fasting calorie restriction and exercise
and that was a big deal that was a
paradigm shift in thinking there was a
lot of debate an argument we're all over
that now we all agree so essentially
it's just so I understand there are
specific control genes that you can
identify and when you just tweak those
it has that downstream impact that
you're seeking right so the analogy
would be you've got your your body is a
car it wears out but what we didn't
realize until the 1990s what that but
there were there were body shop repair
people who go in and they constantly fix
you it's just that as you get older they
become decrepit themselves and they
don't work very hard and we've now got
these genetic and increasingly
pharmacological ways and dietary ways of
getting them out of data earlier in the
morning and fixing your body but then
the next big change that happened was
that we we asked the question well what
are these
jeopardy repaired genes actually doing
downstream to to keep the body healthy
in other words why does calorie
restriction work so well and we in the
aging field have come up with eight or
nine what we call the hallmarks of aging
that the underlying causes of aging from
Chilam a lost mitochondrial decayed
proteins misfolding but I think there's
actually one of those pieces of the pie
one of those eight or nine that's above
all of them that rules them all and this
is what I think is that the basis of
what I'm calling the information theory
of aging and how we came across that's
pretty interesting story that goes all
the way back to my original days at MIT
in the 90s well do tell we'll do so that
when I when I got to the to MIT what I
wanted to figure out and don't forget I
was in a dream team of people so I'm
certainly not taking credit for for most
of this but one of the things I was
personally excited about was trying to
figure out why don't ye cells live
forever because they're small they're
pretty simple and what we and and the
team for sure deserves credit for
finding was that there's a set of genes
in yeast cells and also in our bodies as
well though at the time we didn't know
it that sense the environment so when a
yeast cell is hungry or it has too much
temperature change and make it hot make
it really cold or you subtract out some
amino acids it will live longer and that
is because it's activating a set of
genes called the sirtuins
and their culture tunes because their
first yeast gene was called sir - now
what's key to this whole information
theory is that sir - is an acronym
stands for silent information regulator
number two the number two doesn't matter
but the silent information regulator is
a really big deal and we didn't
understand it at first so just a little
bit about genetics silent information is
essentially a gene that switched off and
stays off and in yeast that's the genes
that control whether a yeast cell is a
male or female so
to that gene was known already to yeast
biologists in the 1980s to silence genes
to keep them off and what the lab that I
was in guarantees lab discovered is that
if you mutate these surgeons or to
answer three so four genes the yeast
cells live longer hmm we didn't know
that a silent silencing gene would have
anything to do with longevity we thought
that we'd find an antioxidant gene or
something like that or a mutation fixer
but out came the silencing what we now
known is that know as an epigenetic
right regulator and that was that blew
everyone away but it was very confusing
why would a gene regulator have any
impact on longevity but what I think now
is that the major cause of Aging
is a loss not of the genetic information
but the epigenetic information of the
body so explain the difference between
genetics and epigenetics right so
genetics is really easy it's just the
atcg code in in the DNA strand it's
digital information instead of being
zeros and ones it's four letters mmm
chemical letters and that genome is
split up into various little sections
that we call genes that typically make
proteins and they take care of us but
what we haven't really talked much about
in the public is the epigenome because
in part because it was much harder to
study we've only just got the tools now
to read the whole epigenome but really
put simply if we could take a journey
inside the cell and then delve into the
nucleus where all the DNA is we wouldn't
see it just flopping around the DNA
strand is very tightly packaged in other
proteins called histones and those
histones can be tightly bundled up with
the DNA basically DNA wraps twice around
a histone and then moves on to another
one like a bead on a string and those
histones come together very tightly to
silence genes so that's what the
sirtuins do they they bundle up the
genes so that they get switched off or
the histones might be spread out and
they allow the cell to read the gene and
that's how a cell
as all these jeans should be on when
we're young and that cell should be a
neuron and that cell should be a liver
and that's what we call the epigenome
it's the system that controls how the
DNA is packaged and says to the cell
these genes should be on and these genes
should be off essentially the expression
of the gene whether it is expressed or
not expressed right is a function of
epigenetic it's really it that's true
but I put it in different terms than
other scientists that I know of
because degen DNA is digital the
epigenome if you look at it is actually
analog and an analog information is
extremely subject to noise over time the
main reason we switch to digital and so
the epigenome the problem is that it's
it has to be analog because even in the
first life forms that had an epigenome
they need to change their gene
expression in response to what we eat so
the time of day whereas the genome
doesn't change essential right
and so this analog system had to exist
but being analog means that it's very
hard to copy it's also very hard to
maintain in a pristine state over a
period of two weeks for a yeast cell or
80 years for a human and so I'm fairly
convinced given the work we've done over
the last 10 years a lot of it
unpublished that the reason we age is
that it's the analog information in the
body that's lost over time not the
digital in the same way that a compact
disc has digital information and if you
scratch it up you lose the ability to
read the right songs at the right time
right that's super interesting how does
that square with this definition of
epigenetics that's out there that's a
little bit more kind of woowoo ephemeral
this idea that you know you had a
great-grandfather and he suffered a
certain trauma and that is expressed in
your you know psychological behavior in
isn't that part of the epigenetic
conversation it is it absolutely isn't
so the epigenome I think is even more
interesting than the genome which gets
all the attention as the epigenome
doesn't just tell your cell how to exist
at your life and whether it should stay
a liver cell or neuron but it also you
can pass epigenetic information from one
generation to another mm-hmm so a yeast
cell was stressed during its lifetime
its daughter will also be there at that
address and we know that happens to us
as well we've done some experiments in
my Sydney lab at the University of New
South Wales where we we stress the
mother or we make her fat or we make her
hungry and the offspring in the case of
the the fat mother are prone to diabetes
because of the epigenetic trans programs
so fastly but the good news is that
we've now because we know this and how
to control the epigenome somewhat we can
now treat those offspring and prevent
them from getting diabetes mm-hmm that's
wild
so controlling the epigenome polishing
that compact disc getting the body to
reset the epigenome to being healthy and
young is what I'm focusing intensely on
right now and so to extend that metaphor
keeping that that compact disc super
polished making sure you know making
sure the integrity of the analog aspect
that epigenetic aspect of of you know
the aging mechanism is running properly
involves this sir - right like I'm let's
get back to back because that's where
I'm starting to like yet quite
understand what you're saying
okay so sir - is sitting on these jeans
bundling them up and making sure that
they stay off so let's say you're a
nerve cell your pristine young nerve
cell you're in a fifteen year old or a
20 year old young kid the your sirtuins
particularly three main ones there are
seven of them three of them are doing
this they say okay all of the the neuron
cells you don't want to express a liver
cells so let's keep that quiet for the
rest of your life that's what these are
two ones do but the problem is we find
is if the that the sirtuins have other
roles besides keeping gene silent they
actually are very important particularly
number sort one insert six they are
involved in repairing damaged DNA as
well and the worst type of DNA damage
that they have to repair the most fatal
for the cell potentially fatal is a
broken chromosome at what we call a DNA
double strand break and in yeast when I
was back at MIT we had a paper in the
journal Cell that said that these
sirtuins they moved to DNA breaks when
they needed move away from the genes
that they should be silencing mm-hmm
these genes come on
temporarily probably as a stress
response and then they have to repair
the break and then they hopefully go
back to where they came from the problem
is we found in yeast and we are finding
this also in mammals is that they don't
always find their way back to where they
started and so you over time you lose
the youthful gene expression thanks to
the look miss localization of the
sirtuins and and other proteins not just
soar towards but there are bellwether of
this CD scratching so they're sort of
like ambulances or you know the
california highway construction crew
who's been dispatched to a certain you
know pothole or problem they fix it but
over time they start to the radios don't
work on the way home and they get lost
that yeah I got better myself right and
and the worst part about it is that it's
it's a positive feedback in the sense
that now you've got some these pothole
workers who've lost their way and you're
not fixing the potholes as well haha and
you get more and more potholes which
distracts these workers even more and
this is why after age 40 particularly
after age 50 you get this massive
decline in health oh and we have
actually engineered yeast cells and a
mouse in a way that we can distract
those Sur proteins and and see them age
more rapidly essentially create some few
extra potholes and distract those
workers and we we actually do see that
aging goes faster but the good news is
interesting um for the for the mice
anyone who's worried about our animals
we have ways of reversing that now
mmm-hmm and one of the things that
you've discovered in the search too
try to create greater functionality here
is the impact of something called nad on
this process right exactly so the
sirtuins
turn out to be enzymes and very special
enzymes what think of them as the the
crew that that's directing the pothole
repairs and you know like I said the
bodyshop repair people they literally
modify other proteins to do a better job
at repairing the body and by modifying
that they remove chemical groups called
asset ills and in doing that they can
actually have a much bigger impact on
the body than just one enzyme alone they
control hundreds of other repair enzymes
but they only work they can only remove
that little s atul piece of other
proteins if they have nad around
technical code in terms we call it a co
substrate but that just basically means
if you don't have any d the sirtuin
enzymes they can't silence genes they
can't repair DNA and by the way without
nad you're dead in a matter of minutes
almost like the key sustenance for
sirtuins exactly but nad is a pretty
boring molecule at least it was until
sirtuins were discovered it's needed for
basic biochemical reactions in the body
and you can find it in textbooks if if
you studied biology in college you would
have read about nad and before we came
along people have really forgotten about
nad they said it's a housekeeping
molecule we've you know everything we
need to know about any D and then along
come the sirtuins and it's Wow nad isn't
just there to keep us to do chemical
reactions it's sensing how much food we
eat preferably less how much we exercise
preferably more and even things like hot
and cold and in the yeast cells turns
out if you stress those yeast cells a
little bit with those treatments you
turn on the ability to make more nad for
the sirtuins do a better job and so now
you can have the sirtuins keeping those
genes silent and also repairing the DNA
and finding their way back home much
more easily so nad is the best way
we know of to keep those her to ins
active and able to cope with that repair
and silencing process and as we age do
we develop a deficiency of nad yeah we
do that's the sad thing is that when you
measure nad and animals and also in
humans we have about half the levels we
once did once you reach some almost 50
now
I haven't measure INAT levels but I
would say it's probably based on the
studies about half of what it was when I
was 20 which is a scary thought this is
a molecule that's needed for life it's
we now know it's a molecule needed for
sirtuins but we've also found that many
diseases are associated if not caused by
low nad levels and so I think one of the
approaches that the we're taking has a
lot of promise which is to give the body
extra precursors to nad to raise those
levels back up to youthful levels and
let the sirtuins do their work and this
is the N and a man that's an amine any
men don't confuse it with MMS that
they're not as good for you probably how
I know it's tasty it's actually it I
have tasted it in a man and it's pretty
sweet it's it's a not a bad molecule so
often people wonder what is nm in its
stands for nicotinamide mono nucleotide
actually the nucleotide part of it
interestingly is related to DNA it's one
of the early molecules that formed on
the planet when we first had life but
anyway in a in a man is taken up by the
cells you can eat it you can give it to
mice in their water supply it goes into
the body very rapidly and the body turns
it into nad in one step and that step is
what gets activated by stress so go back
to yeast for example when we shock the
yeast with a lack of glucose sugar or
give them a bit of heat or take away
amino acids they will make my nad by
converting this intermediate into nad
and we think that's true for the body as
well for our bodies when we exercise if
we go hungry we see more nad produced
still over time and this is this is a
product of hormesis stress stressing the
body to create a favorable downstreamers
exactly so hormesis is is that the crux
of why exercise and dieting is good for
you why calorie restriction makes
animals live longer and we didn't know
that until the early 2000s but all of
this came together and then we figured
out a for yeast this entire pathway and
then we've been working on testing
whether that hypothesis in or at least
that fact in yeast is true in us as well
and so far
it looks like it's surprisingly similar
to what we learned there right so you've
developed this nmn I guess you would
call it a supplement
yeah supplement product this is
something that you take your skin looks
amazing there's not a gray hair on your
head
you're 50 right looking very useful a
good ambassador of the work that you do
and this is very interesting
so by supplementing this you are
basically taking out an insurance policy
that allows your sirtuins to function
the way that they're supposed to without
this degrading impact over time is that
an accurate assessment of the idea here
yes you've got it and so I don't know
whether these molecules that I take are
going to be helpful but I do know that
they're not hurting me
as you said and if I'm around no and all
my colleagues are old will know
something is happening but yeah um
what's important I think for your
listeners to know is I am trying to get
these molecules at least tested if not
proven hopefully to work in people and
so that requires a lot of time and money
and effort right and so there are
ongoing clinical trials
one of them's run out of Harvard
University at the Brigham and Women's
Hospital and where early-stage we've
just done the safety studies but later
this year we should have a readout of
what we call efficacy which would be
testing whether what we see in the mice
some of it is recapitulated in older
patients as well and eventually I want
this to be a
that will treat diseases as well right
so yeah so FDA approved the pharma route
not the supplement route right it's very
hard to straddle both actually I think
it's impossible to straddle both and so
I've chosen to take the farmer route
because I want to be able to have
something that is proven to work is safe
and I just think that for me is is the
better path for me I want to be someone
that is not conflicted is not trying to
promote anything I never sell products
or trying to endorse anything and so
people can come to me and or I can give
lectures freely and people can know that
I have no hidden agenda mm-hmm but you
have your hands and all kinds of
companies out there you're very
enterprising entrepreneurial scientist
well I do but there's nothing you can
buy from me so there's nothing I'm gonna
gain really immediately but I do I do
entrepreneurial activities not because
I'm I just I'm interested in in the
short term gain I want to leave a legacy
and so I've had my eye on that goal
since I was in my 20s and that goal is
to leave a mark and I'm not just
satisfied with publishing papers in
these journals I want to have a medicine
if not hopefully a few of them that will
save hundreds if not hundreds of
thousands of lives thinking you know
forward towards that creates a lot of
interesting thought experiments around
what would actually happen should your
mission come to fruition right so is
your mission to to end aging as we know
it like what is the specific goal that
you're striving towards here well I'm
not trying to end aging I'm I don't
believe that there's going to be
immortality but I do believe that the
wave being going about medicine for the
last couple of hundred years can be
improved the way been going about it has
been take one disease at a time and
study it and ignore aging
and hopefully making medicine to treat
that and so we've been very successful
as a species making medicines that
prevent and treat heart disease for
example but what's that's what that got
us yeah we get an extra couple of years
of life and that's all because other
diseases are still coming along right
behind but we end up spending those
years with other chronic diseases and
we're actually spending longer times of
our lives in a 6-day than we used to and
that's really to me it's it's something
you wouldn't even wish on your worst
enemies is to extend life but not extend
health right if we were to if you were
to identify like the the sort of
ultimate age that we could perpetuate I
mean what is that is that 35 is it 25 is
it 46 like is there a chronological
period of time where you think the human
mechanism is functioning at its peak and
that's where we we could we should just
sort of lock it in yeah well I don't
know I'm 50 and I feel like I'm still 20
so I'm not seeing any decay so any any
age between 20 and 40 50 is fine with me
aha I mean clearly the athletes lose
their ability to perform it at that
level but you know I'm I'm a mental
athlete and in my brain is far better
than it was even a year ago so I'm I'm I
definitely don't want to go back in time
put it that way but what's interesting
about athletes is we're finding that
because we know a lot more they know a
lot more about how to keep their body
young part you know popular what they
eat how they live we're seeing these
athletes also actors take Tom Cruise
looking a lot and acting a lot younger
physically as well then what we had just
a 20 30 years ago previous generation
yeah are you working with Tom Cruise
behind the scenes no not Tom Cruise no
no but somebody else somebody else you
don't want to say well there haha
there are plenty people I get to meet
yeah it's a fun job I put it that way
right right right
well all these billionaires who are
injecting themselves with young people's
blood there's certainly a lot of
interest in youth and longevity amongst
the
well healed so I'm sure your you've got
you know a rolodex of fascinating people
that are trying to get your time it's
true and I help as much as I can and
often I'm asked well David you you're
working on these medicines and how come
only super rich people get access to you
would you first of all that's not true I
reply to every email that I can but also
it's similar to the Wright brothers that
the phase that were in now with with
Aging in that we know that we can build
a glider it's flying we've seen that we
know how to do this it's just a question
of strapping on an engine and taking off
and flying around and we're building
that but that takes entrepreneurs it
takes investment mm-hmm and certainly
the the mm so that the 19th early 1900s
required millions of dollars of
investment and who are the first people
that were flying was probably wealthy
people people who knew others and it's
not so much elitism it's just that's how
all technology rolls out and so the I
see this as going rapidly as possible to
people and my mission to roll this out
to everybody on the planet and not just
wealthy nations I've pledged to make the
drugs that I'm making available to
everybody on the planet as soon as
possible well it is true that people are
looking you know more youthful in their
later years and we're seeing athletes
who are performing at a very high level
at ages that people would have thought
was impossible you know 15 years ago and
that super interesting and I would
imagine that's a function of a multitude
of factors including you know people
have to these athletes have to make
there has to be a way for them to make a
living so that they can continue to do
this but one of the things that was
super interesting about the studies that
you've done on mice with nad and nmn was
the increased blood flow that was
created that led these mice to have like
this something like a sixty to eighty
percent boost in their ability to like
be on a treadmill and
and produce you know an athletic output
I mean I read that I was like wow like
what's the athletic implications of that
is this doping or is this like cool like
what's happening here well it it it's
certainly cool science whether or not
it's it should be considered doping or
not I'm not really sure because we're
talking about boosting a natural
molecule that's in your body anyway it's
increasing blood flow right it's like
it's improving like your vascular
delivery system it is so let me explain
how that works what we discovered was
that the sirtuins let's go back to those
guys again in the lining of your blood
vessels they're not very active as you
get older and one of the main reasons
that you don't respond well to exercise
you know if you're 70 or 80 maybe even
younger and you exercise you still
aren't a super athlete because they're
what we think is the major reason one of
the main reasons is that the lining of
your blood vessels the sort Owens 31 is
the main gene isn't doesn't have enough
nad around and what was remarkable was
that we could treat mice with the
sentiment molecule just give it to them
in their water supply raise the nad
levels back up to young levels in the
blood vessels and now we had old mice
that first of all they they acted as
though physically they'd been training
but they hadn't been but also if we gave
them animun on top of exercise they
became super athletes beyond what
exercise alone could get them as wild
and it it's super cool as well because
the one of the major causes of
disability and frailty as we get older
even into our 60s and 70s why do we feel
tired when we wear older is because we
don't have enough for this blood flow
and very few people have ever thought to
figure out why that is and so that's why
we jumped on that and and so imagine
it's great for young people as well I
think it's it could keep people in
tip-top shape especially people who
cannot exercise as much as they want
like myself who types for a living but
more importantly far more important than
people like me is those people who are
already frail
you know people who are in bed or who
are who cannot really walk very far we
give them potentially these nad boosters
as we call them let's call it that MIB
66 which is the drug form of what we're
developing give it to them for a few
weeks and they hopefully what I hope is
we'll see as they have the energy that
the new blood flow they can start to
walk again and that's a virtual a
virtuous cycle a positive feedback in a
good way so that they get out of bed
they walk they get more exercise and get
back into mobility because it's the lack
of mobility that ends up killing yeah
yeah yeah and what are the implications
on arthrosclerosis like is it it can it
reverse arterial damage and create you
know greater plasticity like how does
that work oh we haven't just Adana men
on that but others have and we find that
this sort one certain is extremely
important for protecting the the
cardiovascular system from from plaque
as well as keeping it youthful and so
there was a study by Doug seals at the
University of Colorado just to mention a
much an independent study they gave nmn
two old mice and similar to the way we
saw new blood vessels growing they saw
that the existing blood vessels had had
much better plasticity and resilience as
well and so the hope is if we can get
these molecules to be super potent and
targeted to the right part of the body I
will have all of those effects on people
and just this also have implications for
mitochondrial decline because isn't that
another key aspect of aging well it does
and just to preface that often what I'm
saying sounds too good to be true
because it's pretty awesome every time
people ask me that yeah it does that it
cures this just that well first of all
we're still in mice we don't know if it
works in humans but what we're gonna
figure that out in the next year or so
but yeah you asked me about mitochondria
we've published these are all cell and
science papers so these are top studies
these aren't just off the right kind of
stuff so a lot of work has gone into
them what we showed in mitochondria was
raising the levels of nad in cells fixed
what was a really curious defect that
happens as the mice got older so what
was that but we found is that the
organelles the different parts of the
cell that have different genomes so we
have the nuclear genome our chromosomes
but also have mitochondrial DNA inside
those mitochondria huh we found that
those two genomes were not communicating
as the mice got older and so we called
it genome asynchrony and it's
essentially if you want to put into a
some sort of a an analogy a metaphor
it's as though you when you're young and
you're a young couple the the people get
along they're in a small apartment they
communicate well but by the end of it
they can't can't stand each other
they're not communicating we see that
with the mitochondria staring at their
phones at dinner not talking to each
other yeah I mean imagine how bad that
is for our bodies and we so we figured
out why that occurs and traced it all
the way back to the lack of nad so by
replacing the replenishing the nad
mitochondria started communicating the
new clues that mitochondria said to the
nucleus hey give us some protein like
you used to when we were young and that
completely restored the function of
those mitochondria in the muscle and so
we called that reversal of aspects of
aging in fact those muscles that we
looked at in those mice those mice were
two years old and within just a I think
it was two weeks of treatment they were
just like a young Mouse Wow
the implications are insane for
something like this I mean that's
amazing are there any negative
consequences of this I just feel like
there's a there's often a hubris in
humans with this sort of thing in our
reductionist scientific method to zero
in on one thing and we see this positive
implication and we are blind to you know
all these other aspects of what goes on
because it's a holistic machine you know
there's a lot going on just you know
there's a lot of dominoes that are
stacked up against each other here
that's right and part of the problem I
think with medicine and and why
pharmaceutical industries had trouble
making drugs with without side effects
is that they are first of all that
they're using synthetic molecules that
the body has never seen in part to
patent protection and supercharged
molecules but also that the problem is
that they're intervening in aspects of
the body that normally don't change and
it would be like revving up a Mini
Coopers engine but not making sure that
they have the right gearbox and tires to
deal with it
and so the approaches we take we try to
change those parts of the body's body
that changes naturally mm-hmm when we
exercise or when we diet and that's why
philosophically I'm less concerned about
side effects because they're really just
replacing what we've lost with age
similar to the NAD levels but are there
side effects well we haven't seen any
we've just been giving nmn to mice for
the last year or so we haven't finished
the study and thank you to all of the
the people online who crowd-sourced fund
that start fund in that study but we're
already seeing a lifespan extension in
those mice and so that's exciting and
every time you see a lifespan extension
in the mice it's hard to argue that
we're hurting them now maybe there's
something going on but maybe they did
pressed or something but other than that
they are otherwise perfectly healthy now
again these are mice we haven't treated
humans so that's why we're doing these
safety studies I don't stay up at night
worrying about the side effects given
what I've seen over the last year in
many years in many labs across the world
there have been thousands of animals
treated with these molecules nothing
that rings alarm bells but if you wanted
to push me right rich says David you got
to come up with one thing that you could
see might be negative it would be blood
vessel growth if you have a tumor
already that needs a good blood supply
and we grow more blood vessels that
would not be good and so that's actually
why we've done a couple of studies in
Mouse in Mouse cancer models and given
them an MN
and the good news for the listeners is
that we've not seen any deterioration or
an acceleration of those cancers and in
one case we saw that the tumors grew
much more slowly then without the nmn
but that doesn't really mean that it's
perfectly safe so that's it's one of the
reasons why I'm doing these clinical
trials is that first of all I want to be
the first person to know if it's unsafe
my family definitely wants to know that
but I want to be able to sleep soundly
knowing that I'm not doing any harm to
anybody yeah
me being a non-scientist I've been
operating under this idea that you know
part of aging is a result of free
radical damage and that we should be
eating a lot of antioxidants to combat
this free radical damage and when you
were talking to Joe you were sort of
dispelling some aspect of that
conventional wisdom so can you explain
that a little bit yes if free radicals
are part of the story but really it
looks like just a minor part of it so
free radicals will will cause DNA damage
we know that and it'll cause those DNA
breaks that scratch the CD so that I'm
not saying that they're not completely
that they're irrelevant but amongst
Iselle oxidation so oxidation you don't
want it but let's go back to that car
analogy I think we've in terms of the
free radical idea it's as though we've
said hey you know what the windscreen
wiper blades are old let's replace those
as to fix those windscreen wipers not
realizing that that's the least of our
problems we've got other things that we
could do to keep our bodies healthy and
so that and you know there's a lot of
studies in in the world now that of
where people have tried to use
antioxidants and fail to extend lifespan
in animals there are some success
stories but you can also think of other
reasons why those molecules as nth
quote-unquote antioxidants have actually
worked and one reason that I think is
plausible is that those antioxidants
that typically come from the plant world
are engaging the
sirtuins and other survival longevity
mechanisms so that they're not only
mopping up free radicals but they're
engaging our survival systems as well
Andres Perez Vera troll would be one of
those right so that's what got me
started thinking about this but if you
look into the the science of this and
the literature pretty much every
molecule that we take in from plants
that has medicinal properties let's say
ECG C from T what else our aspirin is
also a good example these molecules have
so many different effects on different
parts of the cell different pathways and
so they might activate mpk while they're
inhibiting mTOR while they're activating
sort ones that cannot be a coincidence
that these plant molecules have all the
right impact on these longevity pathways
it's as though we've I would say the
only explanation no take it back the
main explanation I think is that we've
evolved to sense the plants stress
conditions so that we hunker down when
we're gonna run out of food there is one
other explanation that is that these
molecules and plants we make something
quite similar but we just don't know
what they are yet hmm so there might be
a human resveratrol that we haven't
found yet right right and and so
basically the resveratrol which is that
which is an antioxidant is also a
plant's stress response to you know some
external event right in order to defend
itself and make its itself stronger and
by taking that in we're having a similar
impact on our own cell structure that's
exactly right
and so we found pockets in proteins that
sense how much resveratrol is in the
body so oneness sirtuin that I've been
talking about has a pocket that
resveratrol sticks in and it activates
it we know that a great detail down at
the atomic level but these other
molecules also happen to bind at the
right place on these proteins so it's
exactly what you said which is that when
the plant is stressed it's making its
own molecules like resveratrol to
survive plants have sirtuins sirtuins
have found even in bacteria and I don't
think the plants are trying to make us
healthy but we
use them as a way to make ourselves
healthy and we've learned over the last
few thousand years or maybe longer that
if you eat these types of foods at this
time of year and you bottle it and keep
it dark and put some alcohol in there
it'll preserve those molecules and
you'll get some health benefits as well
you might get tipsy as well but we've
had to do that empirically rather than
knowing exactly how it's been working
right and it's it's problematic as well
because it's not as binary as we would
imagine there were all those
beta-carotene studies like if you you
know if you take base you know super
dose with this it will combat all these
things and make you healthier in all
these different ways but whether it was
a bioavailability issue or you know it's
like when we extract these healthy you
know aspects of a plant and take them in
a singular dose it doesn't quite have
the impact that it does when it's in the
complex matrix of the plant food itself
100% you hit on something that I think
about a lot which is so we've been just
taking the plain resveratrol molecule
but when you drink it in red wine or you
take it in it's a natural form all of
these molecules are coming with a
cocktail that's probably finely tuned
our bodies are finely tuned too and also
what we find is these combination of
molecules are actually synergistic so
for example if you take quercetin core
settings i'll call it at the same time
with resveratrol they will both last
longer in the body mm-hmm and by
separating these out which we like to do
is reduction as scientists we're losing
some of that and also that the other
problem is that if you're just using a
plain chemical like resveratrol of
course certain these are fairly
insoluble so most of it doesn't even get
absorbed it's only when it's in its
natural state when it's combined with
sugars and in many cases fats that's
important to help the uptake and that's
why often when people ask me how it's
resveratrol would you need to take to
have an impact I have to be careful
because sure if you take it in its pure
form you need hundreds of glasses of red
wine but if you drink a few glasses of
red wine for a decade not that I'm
advocating that but there are some signs
that that combination of molecules with
the alcohol that helps the absorption
could be way better work way better
delivery vehicle than just eating a
spoonful of rest powder which is like
brick dust right right right
other than red wine what are good
sources of that over his virtual very
little is in the food supply
unfortunately it's a little bit of nuts
and ghost grapes but it's very hard to
get the quantities besides in in red
wine uh-huh and buying it in powder form
I mean how much of that is is just
paying for expensive urine versus real
impact well so I don't really know that
but I do know that that if you take it
with fatty food so I take it with you
ogre or something that at least will
help absorb it that it's very helpful
and part of the fat aids with the
absorption oh yeah
so we've sought levels in mice and
humans that were five to ten fold higher
with some fat included and actually we
had much better results in the mouse
studies when we gave them or is
virtually in a fatty diet uh-huh and
what it what is a what is it about
resveratrol that makes it superior to
say something like turmeric which is
also a powerful antioxidant are they
qualitatively different or are they you
know can you switch these things out for
each other I don't know the answer to
that I've actually spent less time
studying resveratrol the last decade
because of more interested in some of
these other well and now we're beyond
that as well with that's certainly
exciting it's heading it past the clinic
hopefully trying to figure out what the
scratches are in the CD is is it's a
major focus of my lab right now and so I
think that what what the future looks
like is that we hopefully will be able
to take some of these longevity
stimulators any man is just one of them
of course there's Senna lytx which
destroy the zombie cells we've got we've
got metformin which are seems to be
beneficial so I don't want to you know
basically annoy all my colleagues who
have spent decades showing that their
pathways are important too but that
these are mostly preventative what
really we want
do is get you out - no ninety one
hundred hundred and ten healthy but
eventually things will wear out things
will still decay even with these
treatments they're not that good
uh-huh even with healthy lifestyle so
the new work in my lab is what do you do
when you need a a new kidney and you
liver or you lose your eyesight can we
tell those organs to be young again
and literally make it young again the
difference between prevention and
reversal right basically right you know
it's interesting rich that I think I was
one of the first people crazy people to
use the word age reversal in this field
uh-huh it was a shame on you it was not
well-received I imagine there's about
five years ago now it's fairly common
honey it takes a while but you used to
be able to say delaying aspects of aging
and that was the limit but it's clear
from work that we've published and
worked we haven't yet published that
reversing aging is really easily doable
we do it all the time in my lab I mean
similar to what you know once you know
how something works the answer is pretty
simple best analogy is you know Joseph
Lister said hey let's wash our hands
before we cut off a person's leg or
deliver a baby and save millions of
lives probably right now a billion lives
you know for goodness sakes we solved
this with soap same root aging once you
know how simple the process is it's not
that hard to fix well we all are
familiar with this concept of biological
age versus you know what's the other one
like experiential age like you know how
we look and feel isn't necessarily Wed
to our date of birth so on some level we
have a fluid understanding or
conceptualization of aging some people
look older and comport themselves like
an older person then somebody else who's
exactly that same age so clearly there's
something happening here that goes
beyond just pure genetic blueprint that
we can influence through diet lifestyle
and some of these other you know factors
that you're exploring now yeah so
than half some it by some estimates only
25% is determined by your genetic makeup
and the rest is how you live in your
epigenome control which is great means
we have much more control over our lives
than we then we thought we did and we
see that now that the impact of diet is
just incredible what is the biggest
thing that we have control over what are
the what are the most important things
sure well if there was one thing that I
could say if there's one thing you could
do it would be eat less mm-hmm that's
the main thing and I know you've you've
had plenty of people right with that
Psalter Longo who's you know discuss
this at length with his intrument
fasting and is fasting mimicking diet
and all of that and I know this is
something that you practice and are on
board with as well so what is going on
with either calorie restriction or the
way that we time our intake of food that
has implications on Aging or its
reversal yes so calorie restriction is
is the most robust way to prevent cancer
heart disease or pretty much all
diseases it's been known for since 1916
and then a very classic study in in the
1930s by McCain colleagues so we all
agree that calorie restriction or
intermittent fasting these days works
the question is how and what we've found
is that some of the pathways that we
study in the aging field sirtuins are a
major part mTOR is the other which
voltar has talked about on this show
these are pathways that respond
particularly to how much we're eating
and if we eat a lot of food they stop
defending our body or telling proteins
to defend us and if we less what happens
is they get kicked into action and they
they do a whole range of things that
protect us from disease and even can
reverse aspects of aging and so just to
focus for a little bit on the sirtuins
because we're on that theme when you are
hungry
you're nad levels go up and so now
you're such ones are quite active and
repairing the body and they can make
sure that the body doesn't lose its
epigenomic stability in other words keep
those scratches from accumulating over
time and
long you do fasting over your lifetime
the slower those scratches will
accumulate and and so we dot exercise as
well
raises nad levels and your listeners
might be wondering why why would
exercise and diet turn on these pathways
in the first place well what we we think
is going on is that in early life in the
primordial ponds there were so picture
early Earth is Earth's covered in ocean
there's these islands and there's little
pools and we think that's where life
formed this is the cutting-edge science
right now in those pools are little
strands of RNA that have come together
from chemicals from meteorites first
cells are forming those first cells need
to be able to control those genes on and
off so when do you want genes on and off
while responding to stress so if there's
a cosmic ray coming and hitting and
smashing that genome of that little
organism it needs to have a system to
defend itself to hunker down survive and
then repopulate that pond when all the
other organisms have otherwise died off
this is extremely ancient genes that we
have inherited from those forebears of
ours but now we can kick those survival
genes into action by putting our bodies
under a bit of stress or mises or eating
plants with those molecules that signal
stress we call that Zeno hormesis
mmm-hmm you know meaning between species
and that is right now with the exception
of some clinical trial proof that
exercise and dieting is really the best
thing we can do for our bodies Wow is
there when it comes to fasting is there
any indication like I'm trying to get a
sense of can you do it too much our
people who are doing these 30-day water
fasts are they getting any additional
benefit beyond somebody who's doing
vaulters fasting mimicking diet which
actually involves eating you know meals
throughout the day or do we still have a
lot to learn here well yeah we always
have a lot to learn but we know it pick
up a lot and more than we did a few
years ago what we've found in mice as a
field is that and just
that came out about a month ago from
Raphael to Cabos lab at NIH found that
it's it's not so much what you eat but
when you eat that's so important for
those animals and probably for us as
well that doesn't mean that we can just
eat whatever we want and and go hungry I
think it's a combination of the two
things and that's what I do with my own
body as best I can but primarily you you
need to be hungry a little bit
preferably every day but at least a
couple of days a week
that hunger creates that stress response
that this sirtuins doing what you want
it does the the buddy shop or pepé will
actually get your nad levels up and you
can do that with being a little bit
hungry you can also do that by
restricting the total amount of protein
that you bring on board so eating a lot
of steak would be the worst thing you
could do
never exposing your body to any changes
in temperature probably another thing
basically everything that makes your
body happy and sedentary and unstressed
is bad for you and the reason is that
you're not engaging your survival
circuits I call them and how does that
square with studies that are coming out
about sauna therapy or cold water
therapy I mean these are other stressors
right that I'm sure are having cellular
implications well they are but we don't
know a lot I'm unaware of any rigorous
studies of cold therapy and or even
saunas but we do know from anecdotal and
and historical records that even the
Romans knew or thought they knew that
heat and cold was good for you and you
know a lot of northern countries swear
by it at least one said once a week you
want to go into that sauna and then jump
into a cold pool now I I don't know if
that works I don't think anybody really
know if it it knows if it works but like
what I can tell you is it it does fit
with the hormesis idea that we studied
yeast years ago and what I found was
that when you
the temperature of a yeast cell it will
turn on the sirtuin pathway it'll make
more nad give it a bit of what we call a
heat shock we do know that if we cool
our bodies down we shiver a little bit
it will build brown fat which has a lot
of health-giving properties as well
boost those mitochondria which is always
a good thing so that fits with the
science so that's why besides the fact
that it feels really good and
invigorating I think it's also gonna
turn out to be healthy as well yeah I
think there are some studies that are
happening around sauna on you know
vascular health and things like that I'm
not steeped in it but I know there's
certain things that yeah there are some
studies I agree with you that there's
one of I think it was a few thousand
Finnish businessmen who regularly takes
honours and they had protection against
heart disease apparently it's early days
but rich you asked me earlier and I
haven't addressed yet what's too much
and I definitely think you can do too
much of anything and we call you know in
hormesis there's this u-shaped curve
inverted you so that you just have to
find the optimal and that's really
tricky not only because it's hard to
know if you're overdoing it we don't
know what those parameters are we barely
know what the biomarkers are if you were
to measure them in your blood but also
because it's different for everybody
that your optimum might be different
from my optimum and it's certainly
different for men and women and people
at different ages so Valter Longo
mentioned that you might want to
restrict your protein when you're young
but when you're older that come back to
bite you right so if there's a lot of
variables here and it's extremely
difficult for us to test one human group
let alone all of the different variables
well the way I do it is I just overdo
everything as far as they may right so
that makes a plan yeah right this is the
the Zuckerberg way it's a fail fast sure
but you know I really think that that
overdoing it on you on your physical
body so running over doing it with
running for example playing some very
high impact sports we just know already
that those are people who tend to have
to have their joints replaced in their
fifties
my joints are pretty good right now but
yeah back's a little creaky you know
ankles are a little stiff when I wake up
in the morning you know it's like going
out and crushing it and putting in giant
miles all the time I mean you know this
is not a recipe for you know maximum
longevity I'm aware of that but I also
makes me feel great
like I you know there's counter valent
counter balancing you know aspects to
all of this we'll do you measure your
biomarkers do you know what it's doing
probably not as precisely as as you
would I've had blood work done and my
blood work is fine in fact I'm getting
it done again quite soon but it's been
good I tend to get adrenal fatigue
that's like the main thing that I have
to worry about because I'm it's just a
work hour play hard person in general
yeah well if you overdo it you can also
be susceptible to infections getting
holds pretty badly I never get sick I
don't have that problem that's a great
sign one thing that's in common with all
of the people that live a long time into
their hundreds is that they say when I
was younger throughout most of my life I
never got sick
mmm all right well I got that going for
me but I will tell you this my my
grandfather died of a heart attack at
age 54 I'm 52 and I've been plant-based
for 15 years and an athlete and all of
this sort of thing but it started it
started to really occupy a lot of mental
space because I very much share his
genetic blueprint and you know we look
alike we we've made similar decisions in
our lives lived our lives very similarly
and it definitely has me you know a
little more freaked out than maybe it
should because of that genetic
predisposition to heart disease that
runs in my family and just buying things
I died to countervail you know to live
my life in contradiction to that I know
it's it's sort of looming there and so
what should I be doing well do you know
what genome you have I should have that
test it I have no you haven't tested you
Gina uh-huh so we have to hook you up
with one of my good friends at Stanford
you're at Stanford's I know that so it's
apropos that you go see my good friend
Carlos
Demonte yes that the Dean of uh yeah
he's got us out there he's the guy he's
done some pretty important genomes
historical so Kennewick Man that kind of
thing right he will help you interpret
your genome um you you can have it done
at some of the the commercial places if
you want that's what most people do it's
pretty informative I found it's not just
for fun I found that I carry some pretty
bad genes and I'm modifying my life
based on those and actually to bring it
home
my wife has predisposition based on her
genome for ulcerative colitis and she
actually ended up quitting her job and
doing what she always wanted to do
because she figured that she was going
to have a shorter health span than most
people and she's too modified her life
in her diet and so far so good she's uh
I won't say how old she is that wouldn't
be polite but at the same age that she
is now her mother was suffering from
ulcerative colitis and now has no bowel
and it's not very great for her um so I
think that the the genome is important
to know I know some people say that it
don't just don't want to know I mean
there's definitely part of me that
because there's a that sets in motion a
series of decisions that you make about
your life based upon something that may
or may not come to pass so I I
definitely have concerns about that well
let me tell you a story about myself I
had my genome done I did it at 23andme
and then I had it done full genome and I
found out that I carry a susceptibility
gene to emphysema COPD and that my lungs
are not very good at clearing out toxins
from smoking now I've never smoked on a
militant against smoking in part because
my mother died from smoking and guess
which parent I inherited that gene
mutation from from your mother
it was my poor mother if my mother had
the information that she had after her
lung was removed and eventually died
from she probably would have quit
smoking earlier mm-hmm rather than
waiting until she had one long so you
can really be empowered by this
information and I try to avoid dust I
try to avoid secondhand smoke for that
reason
going back to something you said earlier
you said it's important to keep your
amino acid your protein intake low so
explain why that's important well it
comes down to a an enzyme complex called
mTOR and it's called target of rapamycin
so repre Meissen is a it all started
back on Easter Island
we had sagal which is uh he was a
scientist who went to Easter Island or
Rapa Nui which is what's called
rapamycin he found bacteria that had his
peculiar molecule called rapamycin and
he his lab was at Columbia University
and eventually he ran out of money and
he was told just throw away all your
stuff in your freezers and he decided
not to and thank goodness he didn't
because in his freezer was the organism
that gave rise to this rapamycin
molecule which is now used to treat a
whole variety of ailments mostly immune
disorders but possibly even aging and
the reason that we're excited about
repre Meissen or at least molecules like
rapamycin to treat aging is that if you
disable mTOR or you give rapamycin which
is essentially the same effect what you
do is you trick the body into thinking
that it's got a deficiency in amino
acids so mTOR has been around very long
time similar to sirtuins but it's job is
to sense how much meat or amino acids a
protein is coming into the cell and the
body so if you eat a lot of meat what
you're doing is you're telling the mTOR
system times a great lots of protein
don't worry go reproduce grow build new
tissue but at the expense of hunkering
down and repairing things mm-hmm and so
if you're always eating meat and always
eating a lot and a lot of protein your
mTOR system won't bother to defend you
because it'll always be on and the on
for mTOR is actually the the anti
longevity it's the growth and
reproduction
versus the hunker down survive mode
mm-hmm right so longevity dictates that
you want to be doing what's necessary to
signal your body to enter into that
reparative mode right and that's at odds
with when you're younger you want
performance gains if you're an athlete
you want to build you know big muscles
and all of these things that that's all
fine but you can't have both it's very
hard I would I would say and and people
who are who grow fast are have to be
extra cautious because their bodies
especially when they're young are
spending more of their energy on growing
than hunkering down and this is just a
fact but it's probably depressing to
some people that at least in in dogs and
it looks also like in in humans that if
you've got a highly active growth system
a lot of growth hormone it will work
against you later in life yeah but you
know again a lot of it's in the control
of our environment we if you're if
you're tall person I'm not but if you're
super tall I think it's even more
important to make sure that you're what
you eat and how you fast and how you
exercises is optimal if you want to live
the maximum potential I spend I have a
lot of friends who get testosterone
therapy and can get you know HGH and all
of these sort of things and the idea is
it's boosting their you know virility
and their energy levels and all of that
but I can't help but wonder what the
implications are on their long-term
wellness and well-being and longevity
like there's a there's a evolutionary
rationale why these things decline over
age right well you could say the same
about nad that it declines and it's not
good to boost it so I think that that
that's dangerous to use that argument
that just because something goes down it
it's meant to
uh-huh but there have been millions of
dollars poured into clinical studies
with testosterone with no benefit to
to healthspan and I believe lifespan as
well and so in our field we actually
regard those studies as somewhat of a
failure to deliver and so I think that
that the evidence is there that it will
give you testosterone probably gives you
great benefits if you're exercising you
can build up more muscle your more quote
unquote virile but it in the long run it
doesn't help you and probably hurts you
because it's signaling your body that it
doesn't need to produce it on its own or
because it's stimulating growth in areas
that you don't want growth that would be
my explanation I don't know for sure but
I think just telling the body grow build
muscle all the time is basically sending
the wrong message for a long lifespan
right what about exercise what's
happening when we exercise and how is
that impacting aging longevity well
first of all tell let me tell you what
exercise isn't it's not just making your
blood flow around your pipes and
cleaning them out it's what I was led to
believe in the 1970s what's actually
going on majorly is two things one is
it's activating these longevity pathways
in your blood stream and I've mentioned
earlier that the sirtuins are a major
part of that but it it's also having
highly anti-inflammatory effects and
it's able to change the way our bodies
actually respond to it the environment
exercise is a treatment for the body
that actually puts the entire system in
a state of defense and so it's it's less
about getting the blood to flow and more
about getting your tissues to act
younger mm-hmm and that's really that
the huge benefit you get from exercise
so why can't we
diet and exercise ourselves into
immortality yeah that's a good question
because I think that these defense
pathways are not perfect they don't know
how to fully route
the scratches polish off the scratches
on the CD so they can slow them down but
as we lose our epigenetic information
our ability to read the right genes at
the right time that's beyond the
expectations of the sirtuins and mTOR we
need something more potent to really
reset the body's clock now the body's
clock we actually understand a lot more
about that now we can read that clock in
our blood and in our tissues and it's at
the level of the genome and the changes
to the genome we've been working on ways
to actually reset literally reset that
clock mm-hmm and that would be the way
to not just live an extra five or ten
years in a healthy way but potentially
take a 90 hundred year old and make them
feel decades younger pretty quickly
Wow so what are the the big questions
that you're wrestling with right now
that you're trying to get answered and
what would be the studies that you would
like to see conducted the research you
know in your perfect world that would
help you make the breakthroughs that you
know you're attempting to make in this
well but the the hot area now as the NAD
boosters move into drug development and
so that's that's on its way what's
coming down the line that isn't well
known is called cellular reprogramming
this is truly resetting that epigenome
what it is it's essentially telling the
cell can you go and find the information
that once existed when you were young
and ignore all the other information
that's accumulated over time we call
this epigenetic noise in my lab that's a
term that we've had to coin because
we've run out of vocabulary so
epigenetic noise as I mentioned is
caused by mostly DNA breaks and other
things that occur to us but how do you
say to the cell your DNA should be
wrapped up in that those histone
proteins this way and just to ignore all
those other changes that have occurred
so we think we've found a way at least
what early days I don't know if you and
your listeners are familiar with the
pluripotent stem cell technology where
you can take a skin cell and turn it
into a stem cell mmm No explain that
yeah so there's a famous scientist
called Shinya Yamanaka and he won the
Nobel Prize in 1903 2012 and what he
found was that by turning on four genes
in cells and they can be hair cells skin
cells liver cells he can take an adult
cell and make it super young again so
that it now is what we call a
pluripotent stem cell column IPS for
short
those can be made into any other cell
type such as an egg or a liver cell whoa
so you could literally take any any
human cell pull up pull a strand of hair
track to cell activate those four genes
and end up with this stem cell well not
only can you we all do it now it's
commonplace every graduate student it
typically works on this stuff so it's
commonplace but the trick is how do you
use that technology for human health and
we're just learning how to do that now
but what's crazy is so I could take your
skin cell and I could make a sperm out
of it I could make an egg out of it and
I could make a new you that way it's
crazy stuff but that's crazy but it's
doable but getting back to aging what
does that mean
well what what we decided to do with
some other colleagues who are also in
this field is about four of us turn on
those Yamanaka factors as we call them
those reset genes not in a cell in the
dish but in an animal and maybe one day
a human because maybe we could use them
to partially reset the age of a cell we
don't want to go all the way back to
beginnings we don't want to turn us into
all into a stem cell that would be the
end of us would be a giant to our Tomer
or giant cancerous tumor but if we could
just do a little bit just pulse the body
so that it goes back to the it's earlier
age that would be the big bang that
in biology that's just straight-up out
of a science fiction movie well that's
what your face just lit up like a
Christmas tree though like this is
definitely what gets you excited well it
does and it did sound like science
fiction and that's why it took me a
couple of years to convince my students
to work on it because they thought it
was crazy and it would be impossible but
then there was a study that came out
from the Salk Institute done San Diego
from Juan Carlos Belmont his lab and he
did that crazy experiment before we had
a chance to do it he gets full credit
what he did was he made a mouse that he
could turn on these four Yamanaka genes
in the animal once it was an adult and
asked what happens and what happened was
after two days the mice died okay that's
not gonna win you a Nobel Prize that's
not that's not a good start
that's a bad day for the mouse
especially but what he figured out was
that if he switched the system off on
that second day the mice were fine
while they recovered but they ended up
being much healthier and he did this in
a what we call a pro gyroid mouse model
but that just means a mouse that ages
rapidly it's the same essential Mouse
that you can find those young patients
who age prematurely I thought that poor
kids that get older in their 13 mm-hmm
there's a mouse that is a model for that
disease
so the Belmonte lab they turn on these
genes every two days out of a week and
then no it's every two days and then
they wait another two days and they turn
them on again those mice lived 30 to 40
percent longer Wow
so it's sort of like they're getting
pulsed with it right so the argument if
you want to criticize the work and a lot
of people have is that they're just
making Mouse the my sick and it's a form
of hormesis but I didn't think that was
true because we've been working on this
reset button for ages and we thought
that was probably the secret and one of
the things we did was we had tried a
whole bunch of genes for resetting and
they didn't work but now we saw that
those Yamanaka factors could be
important that's what we did was we
first of all we wanted to figure out why
they toxic what why is it hurting that
the
and so we left off one of the genes that
was really toxic
it's called Mick and Mick is already
known to be a cancer-causing gene so
that wasn't didn't take a genius but
when we put in three out of those four
genes turns out that the mice are
perfectly fine they don't get sick we've
now put it into mice and they're
perfectly fine but what we're seeing is
evidence of regeneration and age
reversal in those old mice and because
you're seeing it in mice you know what
it what does that mean in terms of human
health like is this I mean I granted
it's not a one-to-one ratio because you
see a 30 to 40% increase in lifespan in
a mouse doesn't mean that's gonna work
in humans like what are the similarities
and differences when we move you know up
the food chain to more complex organisms
yeah right so the it's fair to say that
we've cured cancer in mice a thousand
times over um it's a lot easier to do
things in mice for some reason extending
lifespan and mice may be much easier
because they only live a few years or as
we live 80 on average but these
fundamental mechanisms that I'm
describing today are found in everything
from a yeast cell to a plant many
animals mice of course and us so these
aren't just some esoteric pathway these
are fundamental mechanisms of living
things
so as my philosophy is that as long as
we don't do any harm there's a very good
chance - what we can do in a yeast cell
a worm in a mouse will also work in a
human because a yeast or mouse is 99.9
percent of the way there it's just that
little bit of extra difference but if
you ask a yeast cell where basically a
giant mouse Wow
so in your lifetime our lifetime I guess
we should say we I don't know what
lifetime means given the work that
you're doing doesn't mean what it would
normally mean I suppose but rationally
or realistically or reasonably you know
given your aspirations where do you
think you will see all of this in you
know 40 to 50 years from now like during
our typical life span yeah what's a
typical life span
it's hard to see whether the world's
going by looking backwards and right
into in 1902 would we have predicted
that we'd be flying jumbo jets and
flying at a moon I didn't think that
going to the moon we're pretty terrible
at predicting we're really badger right
outcomes so arthur c clarke said it's a
very dangerous profession that he was
into predicting the future but i'm happy
to do it
there's nothing no harm in trying to see
what the future looks like and i have a
front row seat so you know I'm partially
qualified to make these guesses so what
I see for the future is first of all
that there are two futures one is if if
no aging research is successful what
does the world look like and that's a
world that's still pretty good but it's
not great pretty good in the sense that
the trajectory is that a child born
today in the US will expect to live to a
hundred and four remember that this
child is going to see the 22nd century
what great things will be available for
them who knows
but even if so even if we don't do
anything we're gonna have longer
lifespans
by the way in Japan it's 107 so this is
it's not crazy to say that people will
be living into their hundreds even given
the exploding obesity epidemic and the
increasing rates of heart disease and
type 2 diabetes and all of these you
know chronic lifestyle ailments that are
being driven by you know our habits and
our diets yeah that's a real problem and
in fact by 2050 half the world will be
obese can you believe right so that's
actually one one of the developments
that I'm working on developing drugs one
of the companies that is I'm helping is
working on an anti obesity drug that I'm
hopeful will be of a large impact but
yeah it's I got a drug for that what's
that move your body and change your diet
dude yeah right I don't mean to be
insensitive there's there to that to the
to this epidemic but I think there's a
lot of people that just struggle with
adopting healthy lifestyle habits
correct but even with the obesity
epidemic which is slowing our progress
that line extrapolates
to 104
now these are these are just numbers
right these are extrapolations but I
think if we're successful with the mTOR
inhibitors rapamycin analogs with
metformin if it's able to be widely
distributed not yet but hopefully one
day if it's safe enough and what I'm
working on and other things that we
could expect to live decades longer so
in the future in 50 years from now the
technologies could be remarkable so
think of it think of this I'm pretty
optimistic but the rate of change in
technology still makes my head spin
this reprogramming stuff we've only been
getting results since May of last year
and we're making advances in leaps and
bounds we've now reversed the loss of
eyesight in old mice and other defects
and that's just the eye
if this reprogramming really works and
it's safe then all bets are off
then we we could turn back the clock by
decades yeah it's looking like now it's
really early and I don't want to get
everyone upset that you know I'm over
speculating the caveat is that it's
early but if you'd asked me three years
ago what's the biggest breakthrough now
I would have said caloric restriction
mimetics and exercise mimetics but this
true resetting of the clock is something
very different it's a lot more powerful
and potentially potentially dangerous
but there is that glimmer that we've
finally figured out why we age and how
to turn it back and that resetting the
clock really resets it's not just
lifespan it's it's health span right
it's not just living to 104 it's being
vital in those later years like most
people you know really don't want to be
you know 98 years old and completely
feeble and dependent on people around
them just to go to the bathroom and get
dressed right well most people myself
included look at what life's like of a
late 90 year old and you know I think
God forbid I don't want to be that age
and it's fair enough but what we have to
remember is that we're going to extend
the healthy period of life so that when
you're in your 70s 80s
you don't have to worry so much about
getting cancer and heart disease and
dementia which is a huge growing problem
and we hope to compress the last period
of life when you are sick the period of
morbidity as we call it and that that's
true in the animal studies that there's
this what's called the compotes maker
mortality curve that we draw a
scientists and it's a curve that shows
that for most of the time people are
alive and healthy and then you get this
exponential drop-off of people and
that's true for worms and yeast as well
and that happens really quickly but
there's this tail now what we're trying
to do is push that curve out as far as
we can so that hopefully everybody one
day gets to live to 100 or what if we
choose 130 and then that period is maybe
a week of being sick and then you die
quickly or actually you have the choice
to terminate your own life when you're
done with it it's super interesting I
mean we've seen over the years as
science has progressed increases in
lifespan you know we used to die forty
then 50 and 60 but as you mentioned you
know in the introduction of your book we
haven't seen the ceiling changed that
much you know the oldest recorded person
is something like 122 and it's very
unusual for anyone to live past 110 that
was true way back in the day and it's
still true today even though we're
living later we're not busting through
that glass ceiling on what's possible
well exactly until now and taught but
with the work that you're doing well I
think that that's the point Richard
you're right about that is that if you
look at the history of humanity it's not
a guide to the future again in the same
way that in 1902 you would have said
humans are not supposed to fly same
thing we've got now technology that will
we think changed the way humans can live
and that people who once lived over a
hundred if they spend their whole life
with the right diet and the right genes
plus the technologies that are being
developed around the world who says they
couldn't go way past that point how mark
asked well
I think anyone who says they know is
lying I don't let me pin you down on a
number
well I'm trying not to cuz it upsets my
colleagues when I put a number down but
I think this guy is a limit I think what
we have to remember that for every year
you're alive you get another couple of
months of life and that'll continue I
think and probably be even better an
event it gets pretty interesting when
you you get an extra 11 months for every
year you're alive mm-hmm because the
science is advancing so rapidly right
right and so we've been very good at
extending lifespan by having
vaccinations and washing hands and all
of that stuff now the frontier that's
left is to actually modify the body and
give it protection from aging itself and
that's where the biggest gains are going
to come from in the future well
everything is changing so quickly across
the board with technology in science
right now that it's almost incumbent
upon people who are at the vanguard or
the cutting edge of what they do to
really also be in some respects a
philosopher like how much time do you
spend thinking about the long-term
implications of the work that you do
should it come to its fruition right
like let's let's put our thought
experiment hats on and envision what the
world would look like if suddenly living
to 200 was normal like what is that what
does that mean for how we populate the
planet and cohabitate in a sustainable
fashion is that even possible right well
there are plenty of people who claim
they know what the future looks like
they don't but I'm trying to at least
model it
timuel with economists and philosophers
and bioethicists I feel it's sort of my
responsibility if I'm gonna be part of
changing the world I need to get the
world ready for when this is coming and
it's not a question of if it's a when
cuz even if I step out of this studio
today and I'm hit by a bus this is still
gonna happen okay so how fast it happens
it's hard to know but I I think in the
next few years there will be one drug
that gets on the market that
to impact aging or at least aspects of
it and it'll just grow there'll be a lot
more so in the future they will you know
sorry to interrupt but like regardless
of whether we philosophize about it and
how much time and energy we invest in
trying to think about whether this is a
good idea or not it is happening
irrespective right and that's why it's
the way we function well that's why
you're right that that a good scientist
should be a philosopher should be a
humanist as well and many of us are
because we've seen what's coming and
vulture is a good example Volta longer
okay so what do I do
so I've been going around talking with
politicians and with economists with
policy makers with bioethicists trying
to first of all wake the world up
because most of the world is still
asleep that this is coming but once
people get woken up and I find finally
over the last few years there is
increasing awareness that this is going
to happen then the question is what are
we going to do with the world what is it
what does it look like and if it's gonna
go to hell excuse my language can we
prevent that and I really do see I set a
fork in the road that if we don't do
anything now this will happen and if we
do something we'll live in a much better
world and I'm trying to push the world
push the needle so we hand up head off
into that that brave great new world and
some of the things that we have to be
very careful with first of all this
population growth there's the
environment there's what people do if
they're taking Social Security does that
wreck the economy to tear their lives
become meaningless of a just a burden on
society crazy stuff like what happens
when you have politicians that have been
around for 200 years and they're still
making policy people on the Supreme
Court a lot of things yeah yeah and and
women what about them so that can can we
extend their period of fertility so that
a they can have a the career they always
wanted to and be will they be around to
take care of their great grandkids and
see what happens to them I mean right
now we live in a world where close to
half of all women take time off during
the critical period of their careers
and could that change and not only that
if you have kids when you're all
especially men who are capable of doing
that there's this response that how can
you have kids when you're 40 or 50 you
won't even be alive when they're in high
school what that should change as well
we can stretch our lifespan and help
span in a way that allows us to have
much more say in what we do early in
life stay younger for longer mentally
and career-wise
take longer to find what we'd love to do
and even when we're done with a career
we'll be able in this new world to have
second third careers have a second
chance third chance at the career people
always wanted mm-hmm not to be
contrarian but at the same time like I'm
just envisioning myself like okay I'm
gonna live to be 200 and be around for a
long time maybe in my 40s I have a
couple kids take a break you know
something happens then 20 years later I
decided like I want to have kids again
they're all gonna live to be 300 years
old because the science will improve and
we begin populating the planet with
people who are gonna be around a lot
longer who may be having more children
that they than they would or do
otherwise yes they're productive longer
they're there they're contributing to
society for a much longer period of time
but I have a hard time seeing my way
around just what I think is the biggest
issue initially which is population
control like how are we going to you
know keep the planet from going past the
ten billion mark into the you know 15
billion mark like how are you game
tearing around that right well who says
15 billion is a problem that that's a
debate as well well there's all these
other problems that we would have to
solve in order to make the planet
habitable for that many people right and
and I believe that they are solvable now
I'm not hoping for overpopulation by any
means and in fact if you if you do the
numbers the rate of population growth
isn't that great if people live longer
surprisingly low
and as the world gets wealthier
particularly developing nations they
will have fewer kids that's proven out
let's look at the world if we don't do
anything about longevity and we continue
to treat one disease at a time
we are already heading for a healthcare
crisis Social Security's going bankrupt
we've got healthcare occupying 20% and
increasing GDP of this nation around the
world we're being basically dragged down
economically by health care costs the
proportion of people getting older is
growing dramatically right now for the
first time just this year we've got more
people over 65 in under 5 so there's
there's a gray tsunami coming that's
right here really that's that we have to
deal with so what's the best way to deal
with that well you you can't just go
around hoping that older people will die
off in fact that's a huge waste of
resources there's oh but mostly
productive we have wise people so that
the solution I think is to make them and
keep them productive members of society
my father who's gone back and started a
second career and helps raise the kids
they're not a big burden on society if
they're productive and they're living
alone and or
they're not in not needing any help at
home and that's a huge cost saving
that's in that it's or not they're not a
drain on society they're not requiring
all these health care costs and
governmental assistance and they're
actually being productive and yeah and
so Dana Goodman who is at the RAND
Corporation he calculated that of all of
the medical treatments that are being
developed from angiogenesis inhibitor
services for heart disease and
pacemakers cancer treatments diabetes
the one that gives you by far the
biggest bang for the economy and for
your life is an anti-aging as he called
it anti-aging treatment and to give you
an idea of the difference to a pacemaker
advanced will extend a human life at the
cost of I think it was a million bucks
to the US economy to do it for a calorie
restriction mimetic anti-aging molecule
it was a I think $7,000 first a million
so it this is a cheap way to prevent
the this loss of the economic activity
that's money remember if it's fifty
trillion dollars in the long run that
it's calculated to be saved by doing
this that is money that can then be used
for helping the environment helping save
species help figuring out things like
energy let me give a really good example
of why I'm really optimistic about the
future we humans can solve anything if
we just put our minds to it and that
that's been proven out I mean these days
of got a supercomputer in my pocket for
goodness sakes in Australia there was a
coal-fired power plant down in South
Australia and there was a big jetty a
wharf where they would just bring in
coal day-in day-out burning coal global
warming contributor turns out it became
too expensive to run that coal-fired
power plant so they shut it down putting
thousands of people out of work in this
little community so a brilliant bunch of
bench capitalists said we've got human
capital we've got this wharf we've got a
lot of sunshine it's on the barren South
Australian coast what are we going to do
with that and they figured out let's use
the sun's energy to pump millions of
gallons of water out of the ocean purify
it put it in greenhouses and these days
there's 30,000 tons of tomatoes being
shipped out from that Wharf in South
Australia and those people that lost
their jobs most of them got a job at the
farm I love that story I wish we could
replicate that you know across the board
in so many industries that are quickly
becoming antiquated and environmentally
you know hazardous and there's so many
problems that that I'm concerned about
that I feel like despite our industrious
nature and our best intentions we we
just fumble over ourselves and are
unable to to solve and and that tempers
the optimism that I have that I share
with you when I see that when I see
problems that are right in front of us
then that we need to solve and we're
seeing
incapable of doing it I don't know
whether because there's no political
will or there that the incentives are
not properly aligned to make it happen I
agree with you and when I was I was
young I was pretty negative I didn't
even think humans belonged on the planet
we should all just kill ourselves we
didn't deserve to be Wow that's the dark
yeah but I've evolved as a good-old
right I've become much more optimistic
that I've seen what's possible when you
bring armies of smart dedicated people
together and that's what I see my job
it's one thing I've found that I'm okay
at is finding a goal and then bringing
people together to solve what seems to
be impossible and you're surrounded by
tons of super smart people what about
the psychological implications on a
young person who's presented with the
this new reality of living to be 200 or
300 years old you know talk about a
change in the incentive landscape like
that person suddenly is no longer in a
hurry to figure things out like how does
that impact an individual in terms of
how they make decisions about how
they're gonna make their way in the
world when suddenly time really isn't it
isn't the ticking clock right that your
grandmother spoke about yeah wouldn't
that be great I think that it's a shame
or does it just create a bunch of lazy
people oh well I think it can be a drain
on society people will be people right
though those of us who get up every day
with a mission will continue to do that
no matter what age they are
and probably vice versa but it does it
does give you a different perspective so
the way we live our lives now we expect
to live to 80 and if we're healthy
beyond that but what that means is that
we're now teens we have to grow up we're
now 20s we have to find a profession in
our 30s we have to get good at that in
our 40s we make the most of it in our
50s we're looking at what what is our
legacy wouldn't be great if we could be
60 or 70 and say I finally figured it
out and you know what is my legacy gonna
be
and just start again or use all that
wisdom to do something brand new and we
are entering a world like that when we
were kids being sixty was old 70 was
I'll forget it and a lot of people that
I knew in their 70s wouldn't even know
how to type on a computer and I find
that people now that are in their 70s
and 80s they're playing tennis and
typing yeah yeah Twitter so we're living
in a different world and just like today
you know 80 is that is is 50 essentially
in the future ninety hundred year olds
will still be just as active as we are
in our 50s yeah when you your focus is
in the hard science geneticist but I
can't help when we're having a
discussion about longevity and aging I
can't help but think about the blue
zones and the characteristics of these
you know little pockets across planet
Earth where we're finding populations of
people that tend to live longer and be
happier than others and and what are
their shared characteristics and of
course it's certain diet protocols it's
you know having an active lifestyle that
isn't running on the treadmill but being
kind of consistently engaged in some
kind of low-grade movement throughout
the day but on top of that there's also
this aspect of faith most of these
communities have some kind of faith that
congeals them that creates you know a
community sensibility that that to which
they collectively adhere and also this
sense of purpose like I think it's the
Okinawans who call it the Ikki guy right
that they're driven by something that
exceeds their personal ego like that
that is fueling their life with with
meaning really that gives them a
contentedness that makes them a
healthier person and able to live longer
yeah 100%
if
you don't have a mission in life go get
one it'll it'll keep you happier and
probably longer leaped as well haha like
you can take all the resveratrol you
want and you know we could talk about
the genetics but if you're aimless and
you don't have purpose and you're you
know mentally you know not dialed in and
you're not taking care of yourself and
you're not eating well you're missing
the big picture
well this is the problem with retirement
I mean it's all it's all fine to go on
cruises and enjoy some relaxation but
once you've lost your purpose that's
when things go downhill and I saw that
with my father actually my father
retired at a typical age of was a 66 87
and spent was about 10 years just
flailing around you know you can only I
think go on so many cruises before you
get sick of it it wasn't until he
started his new career which is working
at the University on an ethics panel for
experiments that he hooked up and he was
excited about life and I've never seen
him happier
isn't that crazy that someone who's
essentially 80 turning 80 has never been
happier or more vigorous that's really I
think inspiring and shows me what the
world could be like for millions of
people hmm yeah my my wife's father was
an engineer in Alaska he passed away a
couple years ago but he worked well into
his late 80s on gigantic construction
projects in Anchorage because the
community there is largely Native
American and they have a reverence and
respect for their elders that is kind of
lacking in most of you know the rest of
our culture and they would continue to
employ him he kept saying like I can't
even see anymore they're like what they
respected his his experience and it was
just like the right thing to do and he
did contribute you know in a very
material way to advancement of these
projects so he worked essentially all
the way to the end and it just defies
that whole paradigm of people you know
this the great generation working
towards their retirement and 401k so
they could live out the rest of their
lives in leisure playing golf and
hanging out at the club I'll need to
discover that that's the thing that
makes you depressed well it really is
and and so society would be so much
better if if people stayed healthy but
also we're able to contribute it's
getting up in the morning and knowing
that you've got something to do right
it's important and on the retirement age
no I think that if you've been busting
roads your whole life you really deserve
to have a second chance so I think that
as nations become wealthier and we're
already finding that people are talking
about a we call a living wage when
people take time off work I would
suggest that the best thing we could do
is people get healthier for longer and
just sitting around being healthy that
they actually have a choice to take some
paid time off to start a new career so
let's say someone who's been busting
roads oh no that's just a catch-all term
for someone who didn't like their career
gets a few years off paid by the
government to do what they always wanted
to do and it can be anything can be
building model airplanes or helping out
at nursing homes but that living wage
would come back in in huge dividends
because then you'd have people like my
father who are helping society it
doesn't even have to be paid work by the
way but I think just getting people with
the wisdom and knowledge that they've
accumulated over a lifetime instead of
just throwing that away into the ground
or as a crematorium let's use that human
capital it's worth trillions of dollars
and we just throw it or throw it away
hmm yeah being able to leverage the
collective wisdom of centenarians who
are mentally fit enough to pass down
their wisdom and experience to a younger
generation and at the same time changing
our perception of the elderly you know
right now we warehouse them we dismiss
them we want to pretend they don't exist
we want them to go away we don't want to
hear what they have to say I mean I
think there's some cultural shifts that
would have to take place as well well
they would I
I mean who isn't who wasn't a 20 year
old who's guiltiest you don't want to
hang around the old five I'm gonna
change
that is not going to change but you know
I think as you get older you realize
that they're they're very special people
anyone who's managed to survive for
80-plus years and what they've seen
especially people who had to live
through World War two then one of the
worst times in human history what they
can tell you about the meaning of life
and also what I've learned in life is
it's important to learn from mistakes
not just success and everyone's had
mistakes but if you can see what the
mistakes others have had in their lives
before you make those same mistakes
that's really the way to avoid the
pitfalls in life and I've really
benefited from having some mentors in my
life I would love to these days sit down
with people who have these stories to
tell about what have they learned in
their life that they could pass on to
future generations right well in terms
of passing on wisdom down the line I
think we should round this out with some
practical wisdom and advice for people
that are listening in terms of things
that they can do in their daily lives to
improve their longevity and combat aging
to increase their health span what are
some of the top things well here's what
I do that's how that's how I convey
advice so every day I wake up having had
a decent night's sleep preferably and
I'll go have a yogurt that I make myself
for the microbiome trying to keep my
microbiome in check I take a little bit
of resveratrol sprinkled in that yogurt
is there a particular brand or do you
have some special Harvard lab version
that no one else can get except for me
cuz you're gonna get it to me right uh
well we'll talk I fortunately have
pharmaceutical grade rose virtual
harassment so it's okay and same with
any men and is that that's not
commercially available can people get
that from me well for you you don't
count because you're working in it but
for somebody who's listening like they
can't go to their doctor and get this
broad drive and they purchase
right well there's a lot of things sold
online which I apologize I can't endorse
or talk about it's just I try to stay
above that fray but there are people
selling things online that and I'm good
I'm gonna use social media to be able to
talk more about it so stay tuned
okay I'll release what I can but I'm
also looked out looked over by a very
large institution called Harvard
University writing careful what I say
and what I do but I also want to be able
to say with authority the science so
anyway my apologies for not being able
to say go buy this product I just am NOT
able to say that but I can point you in
the right direction I think you should
look for if you're going to take a
supplement make sure it's from a
reputable source and there are some
reputable companies some other or not
yeah sometimes it's hard to know there's
really much out there and there's a lot
of quackery yeah so my my dream riches
to have an independent group who does
these studies and leaves me out of it
but maybe I can enable that group to
test things and report on it and that
would be the ideal but I got into
trouble when I used to talk about
supplements I once said on NBC or a TV
show that some of the supplements I've
tested don't have the product in it and
that got some people very upset and I
got dragged into a fight between two
companies and it was a lawsuit and I
lost her a year's salary on unload on
legal costs so that you know is a good
lesson don't talk about supplements if
you can help it you know that said look
for quality brands look for purity don't
take things that have a lot of mixed
things in it you just don't know what
else you're getting in there look for
clinical trials that have been tested on
some products so some products that
raise nad have been published in
clinical studies and so you can go to
PubMed it's mm-hmm Google the words PU
bmed you can find some scientific papers
and look first so to ends look for nad
look for either nmn or it's similar
molecule it's cousin called NR just and
and actually
wondering what's in our it stands for
nicotinamide ribose I'd so that's as
best I can do to help there I try to do
some exercise at least once a week on
the weekends my son and I go for to the
gym for two to three hours there just
once a week well we try to do more but
I'm traveling a lot so hopefully twice a
week at minimum with we have a gym at
home actually I built a gym adjacent to
my bedroom which I can see through the
windows and for a while there I figured
just looking at the gym is probably
helping
I was hoping at least okay yeah mentally
you know if I just look at the treadmill
it's probably good but now I try to use
it more and more especially because I've
been writing this book and I've spent
hundreds if not a thousand or more hours
sitting down which is really bad try to
make up for all of that so we do that we
do high-intensity running on treadmills
and we also do weight training with with
a trainer every for an hour and actually
amp my trainer recently looked at my
body and he said I used to work out when
you were young and I said yeah I did
how do you know it he goes cuz you're
all messed up my arms are turned inward
my palms aren't straight I slouched to
one side and so he's fixing that part of
my body but so I'm trying to get back
into shape is there research on the
differences between high intensity
training and aerobic training in terms
of longevity not in lunge evety as much
there have been some human studies that
have looked at biomarkers and other
things like that and it and also the
relationship to to frailty and what as
far as I can tell from leading up
reading a very complex body of
literature is that you want to do some
not high impact but high-intensity
aerobics get your heart rate up pretty
high until you're feeling some hypoxia
you gasping for breath and that hypoxic
response is a hormetic response it will
stimulate your body to fight back so get
get your heart rate up
they say as little as five minutes is
sufficient I don't know I go a little
bit further I don't see any harm in
doing that so you know 10 15 minutes of
panting but then I slow down and then I
do a bit of jogging as well but it's
that really what you just want to do a
bit of jogging a bit of sprinting bit of
jogging bit of sprinting but it doesn't
seem to have to last for that long to be
good for you just to get that or that
stimulus-response yeah because your body
has an epigenetic memory of those
exercises and so it lasts for days
unknown what about training 25 to 30
hours a week for ultra distance
triathlons and marathons
yeah it's about digging my early grave I
don't think so I've seen data on on
bicyclists has it not the same thing but
bicyclists who I think they were riding
over 80 miles a week their chance of
getting heart disease was reduced by 40%
in old age and 40 percents a massive
number and so I think that you know if
you're not wearing body parts out
certainly your organs are gonna be
younger for longer yeah although there
aren't there's some there's some
research out there there's some research
out there that says long term like super
you know a lot of aerobic exercise ultra
marathoners marathoners have scarring in
their heart tissue and there's some
cardiac implications that don't look so
great for that I'm always getting tweets
from people all the time telling me that
I'm harming myself oh well I think
you're gonna live longer than someone
who sits on the couch and eats potato
chips all the time so I can't speak for
the fibrosis in the heart expel them to
say we're also working on that well I
have a sin oolitic company with some
real experts in the field like I Manuel
Serrano in Spain who cloned the
senescence gene p16 so we're trying to
figure out how to fix problems like that
that it came late overtime right okay so
exercise what about what's your specific
for a fasting protocol look like then
I don't have one I do try to eat smaller
meals I try to not overeat and I try to
skip meals which is pretty easy because
I'm not hungry when I wake up other than
that little yogurt which is just for
virtual solubility and then I'm so busy
I usually skip lunch so I'm I'm
practically eating one maybe two meals a
day by default
I am never able to literally go a whole
day without eating for some reason it's
just too hard I'd like to I think that
would be a great thing I know Peter Atia
does it really well and others but I'm
unable to I think I've got to feel my
brain without my brain I've got no job
so that's all I be able to think
straight right I think better when I
haven't eaten you know you get the brain
fog after the lunch and the lull and the
energy sometimes it's better to eat
without food terms of focus for me
personally I agree with that hundred
percent but then you get to a point
after diminishing 24 hours yeah it
starts to go down
so you're not super hardcore about these
kinds of practices no I probably should
be better I doubt it
yeah but as I've said I'm not I'm not so
worried about my longevity I mean I'm
hoping not to die in the next few years
because I've got some work to do uh-huh
I try to be a role model for others but
I'm not obsessive about it I do have
some bad genes that I inherited so I'm
trying to live at least 80 to 90 years
I'd like to live longer I'd love to be
able to continue working and doing good
I'd like to see where the world goes
with all of this research I'd like to
figure out what we have in our pockets
besides computers when you use from now
but you know to your point I do what I
can within reason
most of my mental energy and dedication
is devoted to this cause which is
finding cures for diseases improving
people's lives getting the word out that
this is coming and this is important for
the world to know about one last
question sleep if so much of what we've
talked about is trying to get the body
to get into its reparative State
isn't sleep the ultimate example of that
is this not something that we should be
really trying to enhance and focus on
for concern about longevity yeah well
the first of all that the longevity
genes that I work on are central to the
cicada in rhythm which is the sleep/wake
cycle and if you're out of whack and you
don't get enough sleep that we think has
negative effects on the sirtuins and nad
levels nad levels will precisely cycle
with the day just before you wake up or
before you have breakfast your nad
levels will start to spike and get you
ready for the meal so if you start to
miss sleep and you get your if you have
a lot of jet lag like I do it's not good
we know that mice when you mutate their
body clock they get signs of premature
aging and in fact if you prevent a rat
from sleeping it'll pretty quickly
develop diabetes so it's really
important to maintain a a good cycle and
reset your body clock if you're
traveling and then the other problem is
that without a proper sleep you're not
clearing out or the the toxins that
accumulate in your brain and we just
recently a scientific world has realized
that as you're sleeping and dreaming one
of the things that's happening is that
those canals in your brain are getting
rid of what's built up during the day
and if you wake up early and you haven't
had enough sleep your brain is still
clogged with that stuff and so you can't
think well during the day which is
lethal to someone like me who's supposed
to be a peak performance mentally um so
let me tell you about what I do because
I missed out on sleep for more than a
couple of decades I'm an insomniac
actually oh wow and with kids it didn't
help that at all so what I managed to do
was to calm myself down at night I'd do
a little bit of meditation avoid the
screens the blue light I wear those
light blocking glasses yeah if I'm
traveling I'll take a little bit of a
sleeping pill
which I need to just calm down but I
don't eat the whole thing I just nibble
on the pill and that's enough to calm me
down so I finally get to sleep because
my brain is so active it would keep
going all night
and then waking up in the morning they
find that that combination of the
resveratrol and anime and a little bit
of coffee really kick starts the day and
I'm ready to go um and by the way please
don't criticize me colleagues for saying
this because it's it's an N of one as we
call it but I find that jet lag is
ameliorated its lot less when I travel
and I use the nmn to reset that body
clock which you know we now know at
least in mice that cycle of nad through
the day is probably what's driving jet
lag as well if and also it helps you get
over the jello now well I find it does
for me and I travel a lot enough I
experiment a lot on myself with this
these things and that's one thing that I
am pretty sure is true is that the anime
helps with that gentleman when's the
book coming out well it's set what's it
do you have a title for it
yeah it's called lifespan a lifespan
okay cool yeah so we're we're I'm just
finishing it up it's an illustrated book
it's got some beautiful drawings
illustrations from one of the best
illustrators in the country and so some
of these concepts like the epigenome and
compact discs they're beautiful when
they're drawn out on the page and so
Katy Delphia has been working for a year
on this book as well and I had a
co-author Matt LaPlante who has written
a book about the epigenome so the three
of us have created what I think is a
unique book unique it's science-based
but it covers everything from the
beginnings of life on the planet to
human history and life in London in the
1830s what we can learn what we I give
the readers a front row seat on what the
cutting edge of technology is today
what's just around the corner because I
can see it already and what does life
look like in the future for our our
families for our family members
including our four-legged ones and
project into the far future of what
the future is gonna be like if we don't
succeed and if we do it's gonna be
interesting either way it is but we got
to stick around to see it yeah yeah yeah
well I really look forward to the book
please send it to me when it's ready and
hopefully I can entice you to come back
and talk to me a little bit more when
the book comes out
sounds good rich thanks for having you
thank you so much for the work that
you're doing it's inspiring it's
fascinating
we really are creating you know a world
beyond anything we could have imagined
as young people and you know it's a
privilege and an honor for me to speak
to somebody who's really at the cutting
edge of all of that so thank you for
your time and best of luck with all of
this man doing amazing work oh thanks I
appreciate you all so if people want to
connect with you or learn more about
your world and what you do what's the
best place for them to go
so I'm active on Twitter and I talk
about some of the research in my lab
we've got the immortal jellyfish gonna
just tweet out at new transgenic trained
jellyfish we made last week so that
that'll be the way so that my twitter
handle is David a Sinclair and so we're
gonna launch a book website soon but
Allah I'll let everyone know when that's
ready cool good talking to you thanks
Rachel feel good I always build it did
you good I want to always feel good
we'll talk more all right thanks man
peace
[Music]
mind officially blown this conversation
which incidentally transpired a couple
of months ago really deeply and
profoundly impacted how I think about my
personal longevity my aging it shaped
some new daily habits that I've been
ascribing to including daily intake of
resveratrol which we talked about during
the podcast for those interested in that
product I'll put a link up into the show
notes and I really hope you guys enjoyed
it please do me a favor let David know
what you thought about today's
conversation you can find him on Twitter
at David a Sinclair and don't forget to
pre-order his new book lifespan the
revolutionary science of why we age and
why we don't have to which hits
bookstores on September 10th if you'd
like to support the work we do here on
the podcast just tell your friends about
the show
share your favorite episode on social
media you can subscribe to the show
that's probably the most important of
all of these things if you hit that
subscribe button on Apple podcasts on
Spotify on YouTube super helpful leave a
review on Apple podcasts and you can
support us on patreon at Rich roll com
forward slash
donate I want to thank everybody helped
put on the show today Jason camiolo for
audio engineering production shownotes
interstitial music Blake Curtis and
Margo Lubin who traditionally video and
edit the video version of the podcast
although this one was audio only
Jessica Miranda for her beautiful
graphics and DK David Cohn hashtag DK
goals for advertiser relationships
theme music as always by analemma thank
you for the love you guys I will see you
back here in a couple days with another
special edition hotly-anticipated
edition of Coach's Corner with Chris
health my coach Chris health until then
take care of yourselves embrace life
it's not necessarily the length of time
we spend here on the planet but the
quality of that time so be mindful about
it appreciate it
be grateful and give back peace plants
[Music]